[Musique]
je suis venu vous apporter deux messages
d'abord notre capacité à traiter les
informations est extrêmement limitée ont
fait illusion d'un autre champ de
compétence mais dès qu'on en sort et
bien on est comme tout le monde on nie
tout nu on apprend à s'habiller
ensuite il faut distinguer l'information
de la connaissance parce que les deux ne
sont en aucun cas synonyme l'information
est ce qui est transmissible
on peut transmettre une information la
construction la connaissance pardon est
une construction intime à partir de
l'information était complètement
subjectif on ne transmet pas une
connaissance il existe d'ailleurs
plusieurs catégories de connaissances
alors va faire une petite expérience
scientifique pour éprouver les limites
de notre capacité à traiter les
informations en dehors de notre champ de
compétence je vais vous demander
d'imaginer par une image mentale
visuelle une ligne horizontale à
l'extrémité de cette ligne il y a les
informations dans l'environnement des
sons des formes des couleurs des mots à
l'autre extrémité de cette ligne et je
vous demande de visualiser en même temps
que moi vous avez la mémoire à long
terme et au centre vous avez une mémoire
temporaire qui fait le lien entre les
informations dans l'environnement et les
informations dans notre mémoire à long
terme
cette mémoire là imaginer que c'est une
marmite
c'est une marmite dans laquelle vous
allez mettre les informations de
l'environnement et vous allez chercher
les informations dans votre mémoire à
long terme et vous allez mélanger les
deux cette mémoire temporaire s'appelle
la mémoire de travail et elle est
fondamentale pour les apprentissages
elle est fondamentale pour la
construction de la connaissance et elle
est extrêmement limité pour chacun
d'entre nous nous allons parler de la
récupération le fait d'aller récupérer
les souvenirs d'un héricourt récupérer
des informations qui sont dans notre
mémoire à long terme
vous connaissez les sept jours de la
semaine en français vous les connaissez
parce que vous les récupérer très
souvent je vais vous demander de faire
un petit exercice donc on va récupérer
les sept jours de la semaine de la dans
la mémoire à long terme on va les amener
dans cette mémoire temporaire la mémoire
de travail et je vous demandais
justement d'effectuer un petit travail à
partir de ces sept jours de la semaine
c'est-à-dire de les classer mentalement
par ordre alphabétique
c'est pas évident c'est difficile et
nous ne faisons pas de la physique
quantique uniquement un classement
alphabétique à partir d'informations qui
sont profondément ancrées dans notre
mémoire à long terme et qui le sont
parce que nous les récupérons sinon
chacun d'entre nous a tendance à oublier
ce qu'il ne récupère pas régulièrement
chacun d'entre nous maintenant on va
faire une autre expérience sur
l'encodage qui est le fait de mettre les
données dans l'environnement de les
mettre dans la mémoire à long terme
et ça passe par la mémoire de travail
cette part mythe
je vais énoncer les sept jours de la
semaine en russe et on va les répéter
alors je vais prendre mon accent
französisch et on va le répéter
plusieurs fois on va voir si la
répétition à l'identique marche vous
aller répéter dans votre tête
manny diego nick star nique
sridhar site via bien tenu de sa sous
botha vaste qui saignait je détache bien
les syllabes panizzi elric stores nique
ce raid a dit via quatre médecins sous
botha vase qui saignait plus vite
panini et nick stone x raid à shediac
hatidza sobota vasques et saigner vous
pouvez répéter après on parle un petit
peu on s'interrompt et cetera qu'est ce
que vous avez retenu pas
grand chose peut-être que les arabisants
s'il y en a parmi vue parmi vous auront
retenu pagny johnny qui fit organique
parce que cela correspond une
correspondance en langue arabe bien donc
répétés à l'identique comme ça ça ne
marche pas pourquoi et bien parce que
cette mémoire temporaire cette mémoire
de travail elle est saturé
d'informations nouvelles donc les rayons
et d'autre part il n'y a pas de point
d'ancrage à quoi ça correspond qu'est ce
que l'on a nous francophones dans notre
mémoire à long terme pour raccrocher ça
il n'y a pas de point d'ancrage donc
répétés à l'identique ça s'appelle le
traitement de maintenance de
l'information au maintien les
informations temporairement la capacité
de la mémoire de travail est de traiter
de 1 à 4 5
c'est à dire de un à quatre groupes
d'information imagine que un choc c'est
un petit peu comme un dossier winrar
winzip qui va compresser des
informations et on a une petite capacité
limitée heureusement que cette petite
capacité limitée peut s'appuyer sur la
mémoire à long terme qui elle a une
capacité beaucoup plus importante et
donc on comprend que plus on connaît
deux choses plus vite on apprendre à
mieux on apprendra parce qu'il ya
davantage de points d'ancrage
il faut donc lire aller au musée
discuter avec des gens il y à de
nombreuses manières de construire ses
connaissances je vais prendre un monde
samedi en russe sous le tas
je vais chercher l'équivalent dans l'âme
à long terme en français samedi sous vos
tasses et samedi je peux penser aussi où
s'abattent cette période de vendredi à
samedi
je peux penser aussi à szabados ava tau
en espagnol et en italien
je peux aussi voir maj2 sous la botte
bref j'avais cherché dans la culture de
quoi rattacher les nouveaux mots et pas
trop pas trop de mots à la fois je fais
ça toutes les 20 à 30 secondes
j'ai parlé ici du traitement de
l'information là dans l'encodage lorsque
la forme l'information venait de
l'extérieur mais nous produisons aussi
la connaissance pour nous mêmes par
d'autres processus
je vais chercher mes enfants à l'école
et je rencontre un homme qui vient
chercher son enfant
le lendemain j'ai cherché mon enfant à
l'école et je rencontre une dame qui
vient chercher le même enfant et par ce
qu'on appelle le raisonnement ap du ctif
qui à la différence du raisonnement
déductif ne donne pas apparaître
formuler une hypothèse mais de ne donne
pas un résultat exemple bien je forme
l'hypothèse que cet homme et cette fin
sont ensemble alors qu'on ne me l'a pas
dit ça c'est une autre manière de
construire ses connaissances sans qu'il
y ait sans que l'on me les dix autres
manières de construire ses connaissances
je vais pas tout les unir il y en a un
certain nombre
ça s'appelle le traitement bayésiens de
l'information traitement statistique
également bien je vais revenir aux
russes et à banque signifie c'est une
banque est en université est signifie
cette université est un magazine
signifie c'est un magasin ya jvous
signifie je vis je vous demandais de
compléter de faire attention à chaque
mot surtout début à la fin et de
compléter par vous mêmes étapes
donc il ya jvous banquier est un
magazine il ya si vous magasinez est à
university est ya jvous bravo ya jvous
university et y est je n'ai pas besoin
de vous donner des consignes et si on
voit ça si on voit je mets des petits
des petits traits à gauche à droite et
bien vous allez apprendre par vous même
par ce traitement statistique de
l'information ce traitement bayésiens
c'est une autre manière d'apprendre pour
apprendre on n'est pas neutre on crée un
filtre ce filtre que qui est créée grâce
à nos connaissances préalables c'est à
dire à tous que l'on a appris dans le
passé tout ce que l'on a fait et on
projette sa au projet ce qu'on appelle
un schéma mental et ce schéma mental
agit comme un filtre les chercheurs ont
fait une expérience absolument
fascinante
ils ont proposé un texte qui était un
texte descriptif qui décrivait une
maison et ils ont demandé à deux groupes
d'apprenants le premier groupe i leur
demander de se mettre à la place d'un
voleur donc qui lisait la description de
laives de la maison et l'autre groupe
devait se mettre à la place d'un agent
immobilier voleurs agents immobiliers
c'est pas la même chose à on est bien
d'accord et bien et après on arrive à
lui ses deux groupes
ils n'ont pas mémoriser la même chose
ils n'ont pas compris la même chose
alors que le texte était rigoureusement
identique lors d'un stage de neuro
pédagogie
j'ai pris deux groupes d'apprenants au
premier groupe
je leur ai fait lire un texte en
espagnol
alors qu'il ne connaissait pas
d'espagnoles il me disait belge arrive
pas a lire ces d'espagnol le deuxième
groupe
je leur ai demandé de lire le même texte
en espagnol et en leur disant de
s'imaginer qu'ils lisaient un texte en
français
le deuxième groupe a beaucoup mieux
performé que le premier effectivement
j'ai mobilisé un schéma mental mobiliser
le bon schéma mental est absolument
important pour les apprentissages
si je vous pose une question un problème
pourquoi le hérisson ne peut pas
traverser la route
traverser la route et vous allez me dire
pascal tu déconnes leiris ans a traversé
la route y en a même qui malheureusement
se font écraser
eh bien vous avez analysé ce problème à
partir du point de vue de l'individu et
de l'être humain et je dis que l'espèce
hérisson ne peut pas traverser la route
parce que la route n'existe pas pour
l'espèce hérisson c'est une construction
humaine
donc vous voyez quand on analyse les
problèmes quand on apprend on crée un
schéma mental
kelly c'est une sacrée irlandaise kelly
est elle de nationalité irlandaise est
ce que kelly a un tempérament irlandais
ou que moi avec toute ma subjectivité je
prête aux irlandais donc nous sommes pas
neutres par rapport à nos apprentissages
nous avons quantité de filtres
l'information n'est pas la connaissance
l'information c'est transmissibles est
d'ailleurs un apprenant il veut d'abord
être informé il veut être mis dans une
forme et moi dans l'information jeudi
je vous donne la forme c'est à vous de
la déformer la déformer pour pouvoir
incarner votre apport this à votre
apprentissage
c'est un petit peu comme une greffe une
information qui vient de l'extérieur je
dois la faire en sorte qu'elle ne
rejoigne et que mon corps accepte ça se
fait petit à petit
je parlais donc de connaissances là
contre la connaissance est une
construction intimes est en fait la
connaissance elle n'est pas singulière
elle est plurielle
il existe quatre types de connaissances
nous avons la connaissance factuelle par
exemple la france a été un royaume et
beaucoup de nos connaissances sont des
connaissances factuelles
mais ça ne suffit pas énoncer les
caractéristiques de quelque chose d'un
objet on n'est pas collé sans pour
autant c'est déjà le début c'est bien
mais c'est très loin de suffire et
beaucoup d'évaluation s'en tienne à
évaluer les connaissances factuelles
il y à la connaissance procédurale c'est
à dire la procédure pour faire quelque
chose
comment on s'y prend qui répond à la
question comment s'y prend par exemple
comment devenir roi de france et il y as
très intéressant aussi qui est la
connaissance conceptuel c'est à dire la
connaissance de la relation entre les
fai et ça c'est beaucoup plus complexe
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que
dénoncer certains faits alors ce serait
par exemple les relations entre eux
vassaux et suzerain dans la france du
moyen-âge quatrième type de
connaissances ce sont les connaissances
meta cognitivo c'est à dire les
connaissances sur notre manière de
traiter l'information et notamment de
monitorer l'information que l'on traite
les mauvais lecteurs par exemple les
lecteurs débutants
lise lisent sans comprendre les bons
lecteurs lisent en money torrent même
temps leur compréhension dont quatre
types de connaissances et non pas lui
qui appelle des évaluations différentes
qui appelle des manières d'apprendre
différents dernier point l'information
n'étant pas la connaissance et sur
internet on va trouver énormément
d'informations vous avez peut-être
consulté des grands sites tout à fait
sérieux qui proposait des informations
en médecine et vous avez vu
que vous avez un corps qui vit mais ça
ne fait pas de vous ça ne fait pas de
moi un docteur en médecine
ce n'est pas la même chose docteur en
médecine c'est autre chose avoir accès à
des informations ce n'est pas avoir
accès à des connaissances
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]